on  to this very famous classic trick of  knight takes d4 and the bishop d7 the  knight of three check in between move  and that's a pawn  or is there some knight takes d4 idea  here  yeah  actually now i'm looking at the  evaporator and diva says that this is a  terrible move  i'm guessing knight cd4 right and if  takes then we take d7 and then we take  on t4 and the black king is just utterly  weak  it's just so weak right this doesn't  look good for black at all actually  yeah and now i'm looking at my good  friend  uh the machine who tells me nah just  take like this and when they take here  just take that too  i love that because if you take on e5  you can just maybe just trade first and  go bishop e5 and that's a that's a  deadly pin on f6  absolutely so i think knight h5 is  forced here in fact oh wow and he  doesn't he goes for the other knight to  d4